these surgeons have been at work for two
hours they're patient has colon cancer
the operation will take at least another
four hours but the doctors and nurses at
Bull Holmes Oh Costa foundation clinic
are getting help from a robot collie
called da Vinci he can manipulate
surgical instruments far more precisely
than mere humans head surgeon benimon
guides da Vinci each of his movement is
replicating the patient's body by the
robots arms every cut is accurate down
to the last millimeter a robot never
gets tired I'll cut to it by I'm the
surgeon and it stays that way the robot
simply makes the work easier and does
what i want to do inside the patient
extremely exactly and precisely if I'm
performing conventional surgery I'm
standing here like this you can imagine
that after two or three hours I can't do
it very well anymore I'll start to get
wobbly and shaky while van old man is
operating the hospital kitchen is
running at full tilt it turns out 1,200
meals everyday robots fetch the food
carts each one assigned to a specific
ward they navigate the hospital's long
corridors to get the food hot and save
to the patient's entirely without human
help the transport robots avoid
collisions with patients and staff they
find their own way to their
pre-programmed destinations when a robot
arrives it's time for the nurses to
start serving lunch
phillup partin infinitas guitars many of
our patients are fascinated they hang
around until the robots arrive or they
ask when the food's coming so they can
come and watch the agosto clinic managed
to save 20 jobs with the robots without
actually having to lay anyone off
management had higher priorities and
it's on you to control qatar finding a
qualified nurse has become rather
difficult these days requiring them to
do things which have very little to do
with patient care like moving trolleys
around is a waste of resources and then
you're inclined to ask who could help
out there and so we simply shifted the
tasks around yes aha I'm rotated card
info log on soon robots will also be
helping out with routine medical tasks
like measuring blood pressure or taking
temperatures a nurse still takes the
temperature but machines like this will
update the medical records that believe
nursing staff more time for their
patients